The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Hey guys.
So, these are our special
guest lecturers for today.
These are sixth graders
from [INAUDIBLE].
Do you guys want to go ahead
and find a table to sit at?
[INAUDIBLE] And everyone
will rotate. [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Music matters.
It really does.
Are you a musician?
GUEST SPEAKER: Yep.
AUDIENCE: What do you play?
GUEST SPEAKER: I play
the snare drum, the bass
drum, the tambourine,
pretty much all
the percussion instruments.
AUDIENCE: The triangle.
GUEST SPEAKER: Triangle.
AUDIENCE: That's really cool.
ELIZABETH CHOE: All right,
guys so, before we get started,
the way this is going
to work is we'll
give you five minutes at each
station with your consultants.
And during this
five minutes-- this
is for the MIT students-- go
ahead and introduce yourselves.
Tell them what you study,
maybe what year you
are, what you're interested in.
And then, if you feel
comfortable showing them
the video pitch that
you made last night--
[LOUD RUMBLING]
PROFESSOR: We have this
to deal with, so just
know that's out of our control.
And we're really sorry.
They're doing some
construction over there,
and it's going to
be a little noisy.
Sorry.
ELIZABETH CHOE: So go ahead
and show them your pitch
if you're comfortable with it.
If not, you can just
tell them your idea.
And then workshop some
of the backup ideas
that you thought
about last night.
And the Cummings
Middle School students
know exactly what criteria
you're looking for, right?
So you can use the
rubrics that we gave you.
And at the end of
the five minutes,
we're going to have the
MIT students rotate.
So Nathan, you'll
go to the back.
Paul, you'll scoot here.
Everyone will just
shift that way.
Does that make
sense to everyone?
We'll try it out
for the first time.
And if anyone has
any questions, you
can always come talk to
one of the instructors.
OK?
PROFESSOR: Does anyone
have any questions
about how this is going to
work before we get started,
or what your job is?
Does anyone have a question
about that, either?
Your job, it's a
very important job.
You're critics, right?
All right, then it looks like
everyone knows what to do.
ELIZABETH CHOE: So, I will
go ahead and start the timer
for the first five minutes.
And if at any point you have
a question about what you're
doing or just a
clarification thing,
you can come find one of us.
Have fun.
AUDIENCE: So, introduction,
I study computer science.
Anyone know what that is?
It's kind of like
programming kind of stuff.
And so, the kind of stuff I
like to do is I make games.
So this is kind of
like [INAUDIBLE].
It's kind of like Fruit Ninja.
Have you ever heard
of Fruit Ninja?
Except, because snowing today,
you'd slash the snowflakes.
It's kind of the same, but this
time you get a lot of combos.
And if you slash the red one,
you lose time and lose points.
And you eventually
lose the game.
That's the kinds of things I do.
GUEST SPEAKER:
Did you make that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I made that.
GUEST SPEAKER: Oh.
I didn't--
GUEST SPEAKER: I've got
Fruit Ninja on my phone.
AUDIENCE: It's kind
of like Fruit Ninja
except don't slash
the red snowflakes.
And it's OK if the
snowflakes fall off.
Oh, and the blue ones give
you these mega explosions.
GUEST SPEAKER: Oh.
That's so cool.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So I have this idea.
It's just, without
programming, how
can you make computer games?
That's what I was
thinking of off my head.
What do you think of that?
GUEST SPEAKER: I don't know.
AUDIENCE: Do you play
games a lot on your phone?
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah.
GUEST SPEAKER: Oh yeah.
AUDIENCE: What's your favorite?
GUEST SPEAKER: I
like a lot of them.
Plus social media.
AUDIENCE: Ah, social media.
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah,
that kind of thing.
GUEST SPEAKER: I don't
really have a favorite.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I see.
GUEST SPEAKER: I play Madden
Mobile and Clash of Clans.
AUDIENCE: Ah, Clash of Clans.
Yes.
Totally addictive.
Yeah, so it'll
probably be about,
like, how can you come
up ideas to make games?
Because, honestly, the people
who are trying to make games,
I'm probably not as
smart as any one of them.
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Because
you play the games.
You know what
people like to play.
And it's not me, it's you.
You know what you like to play.
So if you could make the
games that people of all ages
could play, that would
be great, great right?
Yeah.
OK, well, just another
curious-cat question.
Do you know what a hacker is?
GUEST SPEAKER: What?
AUDIENCE: No?
Hacker?
GUEST SPEAKER: Oh, hacker?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, hacker.
GUEST SPEAKER: Oh, yeah.
Someone who has to invade
the firewall thingy.
Or get through
the security bars.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Would you want to know
about what is a hacker
and what they do?
GUEST SPEAKER: No,
I don't want to.
AUDIENCE: No.
OK.
Then let's just scrap that.
How about a curious question.
Everyone knows Google, right?
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But what do they do?
GUEST SPEAKER: Search engine?
AUDIENCE: OK, yeah.
And then, what does
that make them?
How are they so
important in our lives?
GUEST SPEAKER: Well, because,
when we do our homework,
we kind of look up
on Google a lot.
Like to [INAUDIBLE] stuff.
Like history.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Cool, cool.
GUEST SPEAKER: Helpful.
Very helpful
AUDIENCE: Yeah, OK.
You can also ask Siri on
your phone or something,
like your little button.
I'm actually not
from the US, I'm
actually from a little country
in Asia called Singapore.
So I'm just curious.
Do you all study
programming at your age?
Like any kinds?
GUEST SPEAKER: No.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
Me, neither.
I have never studied programming
until I came to university.
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: So what do
you think programmers do?
GUEST SPEAKER:
They create things?
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah, they help
build games and code and stuff.
AUDIENCE: If you were to be
curious about a programmer
or what can he do, what
would interest you, games?
What else?
Anything else?
I pretty much just play games.
I can't call on mine,
because it's an iPod.
I don't have an iPhone.
I only have an iPod.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ELIZABETH CHOE:
All right, you have
two more minutes
with your consultants
before we move tables.
AUDIENCE: So out of the
random ideas I threw at you,
which one would
you be interested
in in a possible video?
GUEST SPEAKER: Football
games, pretty much.
AUDIENCE: Football games.
OK.
GUEST SPEAKER: I'd say, yeah.
GUEST SPEAKER: I don't know.
I think something
that has to do with.
What's the nearest
thing you have
in your mind that always nags
you about computers, I guess?
GUEST SPEAKER: It
slow sometimes.
takes too long.
AUDIENCE: It's too slow.
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah, too slow.
GUEST SPEAKER: Like, even
when you have Wi-Fi in range
and you're near the router,
it's always really slow.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
GUEST SPEAKER: Oh
yeah, and Wi-Fi.
When I'm in my car, I can't
play on the antenna and stuff.
I can play games that
don't need antenna.
I don't like Wi-Fi.
They should have built-in
Wi-Fi on everything.
So that would be cool.
AUDIENCE: OK.
You know Pixar.
You like the movies?
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I love The Incredibles
But that's really old,
but I still love it.
And have you ever
wondered how they do it?
It kind of looks different
from the normal--
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so they actually
use some computer software
to do it.
It's called 3D animation,
like three-dimensional.
Is that interesting?
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah, I
would be interested in that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, like how do
you draw, but on the computers?
GUEST SPEAKER:
Yeah, like do they
have to draw all the little
pictures of every movement?
AUDIENCE: Ah, that's the key.
No, actually the answer's no.
GUEST SPEAKER: Oh,
I thought they did.
AUDIENCE: It's
pretty cool, right?
What they do is they make a
teddy bear in the computer,
or some kind of 3D image of it.
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And they put bones in.
Just like how you put bones in
humans that he was programming,
you put logical bones.
And then you can
shift the bones,
and they're like
puppets, you know?
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah.
This is kind of like what
they do all the time.
ELIZABETH CHOE: All right, guys,
let's go ahead and shift over.
AUDIENCE: OK, so which
one of the ideas--
GUEST SPEAKER: I
like the last one.
AUDIENCE: The last one.
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah.
GUEST SPEAKER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: The last one the most?
All right.
Thank you, guys,
you're so amazing.
OK.
NATHAN: What are your names?
RONALD: I'm Ronald.
RONALD: And I'm Michael.
SARI: I'm going to sit
in with you guys, too.
My name's Sari.
RONALD: Hi.
SARI: Hi.
NATHAN: I'm Nathan.
I study something that's a
mix of chemical engineering
and geology.
RONALD: Geology?
NATHAN: Mhm.
I'm a second year.
I have two ideas.
It looks like my main idea has
been scrapped at this point,
but I'll still mention it
to you in case one of you
is fervently interested in it.
I was interested in
possibly doing something
on how and why fruit decomposes.
But I guess my backup idea
is a bit more interesting
to most people, which
is how you can tell
if there is magma
lava under a surface
and how you can
detect and map it.
And then you might
be able to say oh
is this place in this scope
having some sort of eruption
at some point or not.
So I have to work on the hook.
But I don't know.
I wanna hear from listeners.
SARI: Which one
of those ideas do
you think is more interesting?
MICHAEL: What was the first one?
NATHAN: How and why food
rots and decomposes.
MICHAEL: I would probably
do the lava stuff.
NATHAN: Yeah.
MICHAEL: It's more cool.
RONALD: You could save lives.
NATHAN: Yeah.
So I don't know exactly
what to say about that.
SARI: What would
you be expecting?
If you wanted to watch
a video about lava,
what would you want to be?
RONALD: A diagram of
the Earth, probably.
NATHAN: OK.
MICHAEL: And have the
lithosphere and asthenosphere
and the layers.
And then having
probably, like you
said how you can detect if
there's lava under a surface,
probably having a
place that already does
have lava under the surface.
And like showing the magma
chamber, and then stuff.
SARI: It sounds like
you guys have already
done a unit on volcanoes
pretty recently.
Is there any questions
that you still
have after that that you
might want to have answered?
Like, really cool facts about
volcanoes, or things like that?
I know it's kind of a
hard question to answer.
Or the coolest part of the
it unit that you remember?
RONALD: How it looks.
I've seen videos of
volcanoes erupting at night,
and that was pretty.
MICHAEL: The question I have--
there's some volcanoes that
are big but they
have small eruptions,
and then they do a big one.
And then there's other volcanoes
that just have huge eruptions
every time they go.
Why would some volcanoes
have big eruptions and some
have small, small and
then a big eruption?
NATHAN: All right, so,
here's what I would say.
Of the volcanoes that can
have smaller eruptions,
it's actually
based a lot on what
the makeup of the lava
from the volcano is.
I don't know if you covered the
difference between andesitic
and [INAUDIBLE] volcanoes.
Basically, glass is
made of something
called silicon, silicate.
It's an element,
and volcanoes that
have a lot more silica in it
tend to be a little less dense.
And ones that have lower content
are a lot heavier, the magma.
And so, as you might
expect, the ones
that are heavier,
when they erupt,
it doesn't just
shoot out everywhere.
It just kind of bubbles over
the side and it's more viscous
and it flows slowly.
And so those ones
often will be the ones,
like the big mountains that kind
of spread out this way a lot.
MICHAEL: Sort of like
a shield volcano?
NATHAN: Yeah.
Those are the shield volcanoes.
And so the lava type
causes it to have
a lot more smaller eruptions,
because it takes a lot
and build up of fresh
air if you want to have
a big eruption from that.
Whereas, when you have a higher
silica content, which means
it weighs less, it's
going to explode more.
And it's going to have
more violent eruptions.
And there's other factors
as well, like water content.
And at what depth the magma
chamber underneath the volcano
is.
RONALD: Yeah.
Another question.
Let me see.
MICHAEL: If you don't
have one, I have one.
RONALD: All right.
ELIZABETH CHOE: All right, guys,
let's rotate one more time.
MICHAEL: The amount of-- which
one was dormant for a long time
and then blew it's
top and it was crazy?
NATHAN: Mount Saint Helens?
MICHAEL: Yes.
RONALD: Yeah.
MICHAEL: If volcanoes
are dormant for a longer
period, when they
erupt, will they
have a violenter eruption than
ones that are dormant shorter?
I can't actually
answer that question.
I know what causes volcanoes
to go more dormant, what
might make them not dormant.
But I can't really say
if that would effect it.
AUDIENCE: One thing about
math that you have really
enjoyed or really hated.
Or two things.
So we'll start.
Go left to right.
BRIAN: Wait, what
did you say again?
AUDIENCE: So name, favorite
subject, and things about math
that you you have really
loved or really hated.
BRIAN: OK.
My name is Brian.
My favorite subject is gym.
And I hate math,
because it's boring.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Actually, I guess it's
a kind of new direction,
but a lot of people are actually
studying the math of sports.
So they go out and do really
weird things with sports,
like throwing
basketballs at, like,
places where you shoot an
arrow, and they do math with it.
So that's kind of a
connection, gym and math
getting closer together.
MATT: My name's Matt.
I like math.
You hear that, Brian?
And what was the third
thing that I have to say?
AUDIENCE: Some things that you
really enjoyed it about it.
MATT: I enjoy solving
variables and equations
and graphing things.
That's good.
AUDIENCE: You're
ready for high school.
MATT: Burn.
JOHN: My name is John, and
my favorite subject is--
MATT: History.
JOHN: History.
And I personally
do not like math.
MATT: Hi, guys.
JOHN: What?
If I had to say what
I like about it,
I'm really into
fractions, kind of.
I just like the idea.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Do you know what about the idea?
I've never heard anybody say
I like the idea of fractions,
so that's really
interesting to me.
JOHN: Like, things like
this table being broken up
into thousands of pieces.
I don't know.
AUDIENCE: Now,
really wacky things
that mathematicians
do later on is
that they don't just break the
table into a thousand pieces.
That's too easy.
They break it into an
infinite number of pieces.
And then they see what
they can do with that.
And, kind of related
to that, mathematicians
have proved that
you can take a ball.
You know, just volume one.
One-gallon ball.
And you can cut it in
such a way that you
can make two one-gallon balls.
So you can make two
out of one using math.
JOHN: That's cool.
AUDIENCE: So that's
some other idea.
MATT: You like math now, boys?
AUDIENCE: I mean, if
you think about it,
math people do
really cool things.
There was a study once where
they analyzed the language
of King George and Kanye West.
And they compared them.
And this was an actual study,
like they put time into it.
So I thought that
was pretty cool.
But anyway, that's not
what my pitch is about.
And I'll just say it real quick.
Not going to show the video,
because the sound is terrible.
What I want to talk about
in this video is just
the question of is
math real and true?
Because what mathematicians
learned in the 20th century,
there was a young man named
Kurt Godel who proved that--
ELIZABETH CHOE: One
more minute, guys,
before we need to switch again.
AUDIENCE: --you can never
prove if math is true or not.
So the arithmetic we
learned in school,
we think it's true, because
it's worked, but it may not be.
There's no way to say for sure.
MATT: Wait, is Kurt
Colonel the guy
who made Kentucky Fried Chicken?
No, it's Kurt Godel.
MATT: Oh.
AUDIENCE: I mean,
I think it would
be really cool if he did math
and Kentucky Fried Chicken.
That would be the best.
MATT: On Family Guy, he went
to Kentucky to get chicken.
And he's like, is whatever
his name is that sounded
like what you said.
And he's like no, he's dead.
And he's like the something.
It was so funny.
AUDIENCE: I'll have
to look and see now.
Did any mathematicians
open fast food chains?
That's probably an
interesting question.
I don't think anyone's
asked it before.
But, that said, any
thoughts on the idea?
I'll get a thumbs up, thumbs
down, or thumbs middle.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Rotate.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thanks, guys.
It was nice meeting you and
enjoy playing or not playing.
AUDIENCE: I want an
aha moment, a eureka.
PROFESSOR: I think you want
to get away from instruction
and more of concept.
Right?
So see if you can think
of a little narrower focus
than in these big,
big, big concepts.
And that might help you
with your next group.
GUEST SPEAKER: So some of
them are pretty similar,
like the robots?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So we're teaching them.
They're scientists, and we're
teaching them how to make--
have you ever looked
on cool videos?
Have you seen Charlie the
Unicorn, or you've seen--
GUEST SPEAKER: Oh, I've
seen Charlie the Unicorn.
PROFESSOR: Charlie the Unicorn.
Or maybe you've seen-- I used
to work with kids your age,
and they loved that one.
It was about this little
snail, Marcel the Shell.
Have you seen that one?
No?
Well, you see these
little YouTube videos,
and everyone's like,
oh, that's cool.
You've got to watch that too.
GUEST SPEAKER: Oh,
like the 21 kid?
PROFESSOR: Which one?
GUEST SPEAKER: The
21 kid that says 21.
Everybody in
America says 21 now.
PROFESSOR: Oh really?
Is that the it one
you have to watch?
21?
GUEST SPEAKER: It's a Vine.
GUEST SPEAKER: And then
they make it into a video.
Or there's a series of shows
on YouTube called ASDF.
It's about this
little stick figure.
PROFESSOR: Right, so
you guys see them,
and then you're like hey friend,
you've got to see this too.
And then you get
everyone watch it, right?
We're trying to make those
really cool, short videos
about science topics.
Right?
And so we're going
to make them free,
so that it also teaches people
something while it's also
cool and fun.
And so what he's
trying to figure out
is what in his world
of computer science
would be cool enough that
you'd be, like hey friend,
you've got to check this out.
It's really awesome.
GUEST SPEAKER: I think
the hacker one would
be good for people out age.
PROFESSOR: To understand how
someone hacked your account?
GUEST SPEAKER:
Yeah, but then you
don't want kids to hack people.
PROFESSOR: Well,
that's the fear, right?
You don't want to end up
giving kids instructions
on how to hack, because I don't
think the government or anyone
else would probably like that.
But that's a fear, right?
It's just making sure
that we're not actually
giving instructional videos on
how to destroy other people's
credit cards.
GUEST SPEAKER:
Google might be good.
GUEST SPEAKER: Because then
you could just hack this ATM
and get all the money.
PROFESSOR: How to
protect yourself,
like make sure your money's safe
would be interesting to you?
GUEST SPEAKER: Like how to
protect yourself from hackers,
how to protect yourself.
PROFESSOR: How to
protect yourself,
instead of destroying
someone else's something?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MATT: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: That's a nice
way of turning it around.
GUEST SPEAKER: I
have a question.
So say if someone
lost their wallet,
and they had their
credit card in there,
and it can access to the bank.
If someone found it, and
the person to access,
do they end up giving
them the money?
PROFESSOR: Sometimes, and that's
why credit cards are really
good at-- do you know anything
about this in your work, or no?
AUDIENCE: Credit cards?
PROFESSOR: Protecting credit
card identity and all that?
GUEST SPEAKER: But don't they
have your picture or something,
so they know it's you?
AUDIENCE: But online,
it's really easy
to use another
person's credit card
if you know all the information.
PROFESSOR: I get called
often from my bank saying,
did you make this purchase,
or did someone else?
But that's an interesting
thing for people who
do a lot of shopping online.
How do you protect yourself?
GUEST SPEAKER: If somebody
else took your money,
would you get that back or no?
PROFESSOR: That's
why, if you catch it
quickly with your
bank, sometimes
they can quickly stop
it before it ends up
getting charged. to you.
But that's an interesting idea.
How, if you're buying
stuff on the internet,
what's actually happening
to protect yourself?
What if someone did
catch the person,
and the person already
used all the money,
and you can't return
it after that,
did the bank end up giving
their money to the person?
PROFESSOR: Do you
ever wonder what
happens when you type in
the credit card number,
and how the money actually
gets where it needs to go?
GUEST SPEAKER: Oh,
they track them down?
PROFESSOR: Have
you ever wondered
about how that happens?
No, not really?
You just care about getting
your package in the mail?
GUEST SPEAKER: Does the
ATM make its own money,
or do they put it in?
PROFESSOR: Do they just
put the money in there?
Every country's different,
but at least here, there
is a central office
that makes money.
And then they just distribute
it into different places.
The ATM doesn't make the money.
That's a good question.
But, an interesting thing for
you to think you think about
is what within these
topics more specifically?
Because the hacking is a
cool topic, but you're right
It's a dangerous one.
And we'd want to make sure
we had the right angle, so
that we're not
accidentally giving
sixth graders the tools
to be able to hack
into whatever account, right?
That would be scary.
GUEST SPEAKER: Google
might be a good one.
PROFESSOR: Google?
Could be, right?
How does Google actually work?
How does it find your result?
Like, if you want to learn
how zebras have stripes,
how does it actually
give you an answer?
GUEST SPEAKER: Or how does
something spread, like a virus?
That's a cool idea, too.
Something to think about.
Keep thinking.
You're on it.
Good, good, good.
AUDIENCE: Virus.
ANDREA: And you are?
ANAMA: Anama.
ANDREA: Those are some
really cool names.
GIANNA: Thank you.
ANDREA: And?
GIANNA: Gianna.
ANDREA: Gianna.
PROFESSOR: So,
we're going to have
to move a little quickly,
because we've got
two teams to talk about, so--
AUDIENCE: You can go first.
AUDIENCE: All right,
introduction first.
I'm a first year here at MIT.
I like to study math,
physics, and education.
I've said it too much.
And I'm going to just
pitch the idea right away.
Normally, I would ask
you guys what you like.
But the question that I would
like to discuss in the video
is whether math is
actually real and true.
And the thing is that
mathematicians have proved
that they can never prove that.
So we can never know for
sure if math is true.
Even arithmetic, you know,
it's worked for us so well.
Two plus two is
always four, it seems.
But that may not be true.
I guess that's kind of the
question I wanted to address.
And out of that it
also comes, you know,
can machines be
smarter than humans?
And can robots
overtake the world?
Just things like
that, so any thoughts?
PROFESSOR: So those were
three topics, right?
AUDIENCE: So that was one topic.
All those questions kind
of come out of that.
PROFESSOR: Those
are big questions.
GIANNA: Are we supposed
to say something?
PROFESSOR: What do
you guys respond?
Do you think any of those
ideas that she mentioned
are things that you would
be like, hey friend,
this is really cool.
You've got to check
out this video.
ANAMA: Mhm.
GIANNA: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Which one?
ANAMA: The robot thing.
PROFESSOR: Would robots
take over the world?
AUDIENCE: They're all
related, you know?
GIANNA: I like the one
that's like, is it true?
Like, four plus four is eight.
Is that true?
AUDIENCE: So, I'll
tell you a secret.
Even though we cannot tell
that math is true, that's sad,
that also means that robots
cannot overtake the world.
In case you were wondering.
GIANNA: It's still possible.
AUDIENCE: It's not possible.
ANAMA: I changed my answer.
I'm changing it to math.
PROFESSOR: The math one?
But you'll get to the math
one through the robots one.
GIANNA: You know the answer?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Right?
So do you have any other ideas,
or was this the big ideas?
AUDIENCE: That was the big one.
PROFESSOR: So you
think if she talks
about the idea of
could robots overtake
the world, and through
that she answers
some of the questions about
math being true or not true,
that would be really cool?
GIANNA: Yeah.
ANAMA: I don't think robots
could take over the world.
PROFESSOR: You don't think so?
AUDIENCE: They couldn't.
GIANNA: Wait, what about that
weird robot with the face
that's creepy?
ANAMA: I mean, you can smash
them and they can break down.
GIANNA: But what if
they try to smash you?
AUDIENCE: So, eventually
we'll be smarter.
Because that's kind of what
a mathematician proved,
is that a machine can never be
as smart or do as many things
that we can do.
PROFESSOR: I like
the could robots
take over the world idea with
all this other stuff connected
to it.
I think that's a cool idea.
ANAMA: Do you know
the show Lab Rats?
AUDIENCE: No, I don't.
Well, there's these three humans
who are also a robot thing.
And they have all
kinds of powers,
because there was this guy
that wanted to make them evil
and take over the world.
GIANNA: They don't
want Disney Channel.
ANAMA: It's not Disney
Channel, it's [INAUDIBLE].
And then this person stole them
to make them become heroes.
But what if someone
that invents a robot
gives them all kinds of--
PROFESSOR: Powers?
ANAMA: Yeah, like a laser.
PROFESSOR: That's what she
was saying, that robots
can be really, really smart.
AUDIENCE: But not
as smart as us.
So I guess, eventually,
we'll win if robots
did decide to break down on us.
PROFESSOR: I want to make
sure Andrea gets some time,
so let's hear your ideas.
GIANNA: Do you guys
have any tissues?
PROFESSOR: I'll go get you some.
You keep going.
OK?
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry about that.
ANAMA: That's OK.
ANDREA: So, I already
know the answer for you.
Are you going to have
to have braces someday?
Do you know?
ANAMA: No.
They're cool.
They look cool.
ANDREA: You want them?
GIANNA: No.
ANAMA: Kind of.
GIANNA: No you don't.
No you don't.
ANDREA: So how long have
you had your braces?
GIANNA: Beginning
of fifth grade.
ANDREA: So you've
had them a while?
GIANNA: Yeah.
ANAMA: I don't even
know if I want braces.
Because you can't eat gum
or anything like that.
GIANNA: Let me see your teeth.
You need braces.
ANAMA: No, I don't.
GIANNA: Yes, you do.
ANDREA: So are you curious about
what they do to your teeth?
GIANNA: Just make them
straight, I guess.
ANDREA: Do you know
how they do that?
ANAMA: Yeah, they
put them together.
GIANNA: But I have
two teeth up here.
ANDREA: And they pulled
them down, right?
GIANNA: Yeah.
ANAMA: You had two teeth
that were flipped up?
GIANNA: I had a
palate expander, too.
PROFESSOR: Tissue.
GIANNA: And it made
me talk like that,
and I couldn't talk for a while.
And it widened my jaw.
I had to key it every night.
It kind of hurt.
You don't want braces.
PROFESSOR: What was it?
I'm sorry, I missed it.
What was your idea?
ANDREA: To talk about
braces, basically what
they're doing to your teeth.
PROFESSOR: Oh, that's cool.
ANAMA: Are they bad
for your teeth also?
ANDREA: Are they
bad for your teeth?
That's a good question.
PROFESSOR: And why don't
more teeth move back?
ANDREA: Why do my
teeth move, and what
happens when stuff gets in.
I just got my braces
off in October.
PROFESSOR: Good for you.
ANDREA: Yeah.
GIANNA: My dad has
instructed me to get
them changed every month, but
it's been like three months.
PROFESSOR: So what's actually
going on with your braces?
That's a cool, very
age-relevant relevant topic.
ANAMA: But instead
of getting braces,
can't you get that
plastic thing?
ANDREA: Yeah, the aligners.
GIANNA: Do you have
to wear a retainer?
I
ANDREA: Have to wear a retainer.
PROFESSOR: I know one of my
friends who had them, still
wears this retainer.
ANAMA: Do you have
to wear it every day?
GIANNA: If you don't wear it,
they can get crooked again.
ANAMA: Every day for
the rest of your life?
PROFESSOR: I am proof
of that, actually.
ANAMA: For the
rest of your life?
PROFESSOR: That if you
don't wear your retainer,
your teeth do go back.
GIANNA: Do you have
to wear it in school?
ELIZABETH CHOE: I
had braces twice.
PROFESSOR: See?
ELIZABETH CHOE: I still
wear retainers at night.
PROFESSOR: And they give
kids braces so young, now.
You can be in third
grade and have braces,
whereas, when I was a
kid, you didn't get them
until high school.
Third grade?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I've seen lots of
little kids with braces.
And you're like, your teeth
are so little and you--
ANAMA: You have
to wear retainers
for the rest of your life.
PROFESSOR: For a while.
GIANNA: What about
that thing that goes--
PROFESSOR: The headgear?
ANDREA: The headgear.
ANAMA: Oh, did you
have to wear like that?
That's so gross.
ANDREA: Willy Wonka?
ANAMA: It looks weird.
ANDREA: Charlie and
the Chocolate Factory,
where he wears [INAUDIBLE].
ANAMA: It makes you
talk weird, too.
PROFESSOR: We're actually
really good on time.
ELIZABETH CHOE: OK,
everybody, it's time
to stop what you're doing.
PROFESSOR: I heard some
amazing conversations.
And you sixth-graders
asked fantastic questions.
We're just wrapping up.
I'd love to hear from a
couple groups of students,
the sixth-graders.
What were some of the
best ideas that you
heard all day,
that you're like, I
can't wait for the
video to come out.
I really want to watch it.
And maybe hear any ideas that
you're really exited about.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The navy one.
PROFESSOR: The navy one?
What about it?
What did he--
AUDIENCE: With the torpedoes.
PROFESSOR: Torpedo.
Interesting.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The idea of
watching things blow up
is exciting to you?
Yes.
What else?
AUDIENCE: I liked the idea with
the robot and [INAUDIBLE] talk
and Wi-Fi and stuff and
you can play with it
and run around with it.
I'd like to have seen it move.
PROFESSOR: So you're
excited about learning
more about robotics
and how they work?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Anyone else have one?
ELIZABETH CHOE: Gianna?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
GIANNA: I have three.
PROFESSOR: Pick one.
Pick your best.
GIANNA: I like the braces.
PROFESSOR: So you have
braces, understanding
what braces do to your
teeth and how they work.
That's cool, if
you've got braces,
so that would be interesting.
AUDIENCE: Someone said
something about volcanoes.
PROFESSOR: The
volcanoes, understanding
if there's a volcano
underneath your house.
That was a cool idea.
Is there lava under
my house, right?
Yikes.
Sixth grade, any advice
to our MIT students
before they take
your good feedback
and turn them into videos?
Anything you want to
make sure that they
know to do or not to do as
they take your good ideas
and over the next month develop
them into actual movies?
AUDIENCE: Use
picture ideas instead
of talking to them, like
show examples so they
can memorize it.
PROFESSOR: So we talked about
that, MIT students, yesterday,
the idea of showing,
don't telling,
which I'm sure you guys talk
about in your writing a lot,
right?
Showing, don't telling.
Cool.
AUDIENCE: Don't ask
too many questions,
like when we watch one video
and it asks a ton of questions.
And we didn't really
understand it.
PROFESSOR: You mean asking
the audience question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, like
saying, what does this do?
What does this do?
If they're just saying one
thing and then show it.
PROFESSOR: So
asking your audience
too many questions is annoying.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: You
first, and then you.
AUDIENCE: Be original.
PROFESSOR: Be original, so
try and have a new idea.
And what else?
AUDIENCE: While you explain
how things work, try and make
some jokes while you do it,
so your audience laughs at it
and they understand what
you're talking about.
PROFESSOR: Awesome.
Last one.
AUDIENCE: Don't use
a monotonous pitch.
PROFESSOR: Awesome.
Change your voice around and
make it more interesting.
MIT students, I'm curious
from you what was valuable
that you got from
the sixth-graders
today, to give them some
feedback about this experience.
Did anyone get
really good feedback?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
well, I found that--
and I should have
realized this--
is that having robots stomping
around and destroying a city
is way more fun than showing
old people doing math.
PROFESSOR: Robots are more
than old people doing math.
Huh.
AUDIENCE: I, too, learned
that my tastes are different,
that lava and volcanoes are a
lot more interesting than food
decomposing.
PROFESSOR: He wanted
to show food rotting,
and everyone
thought that was not
as fun as volcanoes exploding.
Any other thing from
the MIT students
that you found helpful?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I was
kind of-- it helped
me to know how much people in
sixth grade know about some
of the really complicated
subjects that we're using,
learning here.
PROFESSOR: Awesome.
We had to do a conversation
about sinking and floating
and how do boats even work.
It was awesome.
Well, we can't thank
you sixth-graders
enough for coming here today.
So helpful.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
And then, we'll be in
touch with you guys
to let you know how we
get our ideas developed.
ELIZABETH CHOE: And the videos
that you guys made with me
last month are almost finished.
Carrie is almost
finished with them today.
So I will send those
over to your teachers
and you can watch them
some time this week.
PROFESSOR: Any
directions from teachers
before they leave the room?
And coming up next?
AUDIENCE: Nope, just
make one long single line
so I can count before
you leave the building.
And then I'll count
you on the bus again.
PROFESSOR: Check for jackets
and all of those things.
But have a safe trip back home.
AUDIENCE: Did you say thank you?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.